[Music]
for some it's a serious sport for others
just a way to let loose but despite its
casual association with fun and sun
surfing has a richer and deeper history
than many realize what we today call
surfing originated in the polynesian
islands of the Pacific Ocean we know
from various accounts that wave riding
was done throughout the Polynesian
Pacific as well as in West Africa and
Peru but it was in the Hawaiian
archipelago in particular that surfing
advanced the most was best documented
and unlike elsewhere in Polynesia
persisted and for the people of Hawaii
waves sliding was not just a
recreational activity but one with
spiritual and social significance like
much of Hawaiian society nearly every
aspect of surfing was governed by a code
of rules and taboos known as kapu
Hawaiians made offerings when selecting
a tree to carve prayed for waves with
the help of a Kahuna or an expert priest
and gave thanks after surviving a
perilous wipeout certain surf breaks
were strictly reserved for the elite but
it wasn't just a solemn affair surfers
competed and wagered on who could ride
the farthest the fastest or catch the
biggest wave with superior skill
granting respect social status and
romantic success though it was later
called the sport of kings Hawaiian men
and women of all ages and social classes
participated riding surfboards shaped
from koa breadfruit or weally weally
trees many Hawaiians rode Alaia boards
which were thin mid-sized and somewhat
resembled today's short boards some
mounted pipe o boards short round nosed
boards on which riders typically lay on
their stomachs but only chieftains could
ride the massive Olo boards twice as
long as today's long boards unlike most
modern surfboards
all boards were finless requiring
surfers to drag their hands or feet to
turn we don't know exactly when wave
sliding was invented but we know that it
had already been practiced in Polynesia
for centuries by the time it was
described in 1777 by William Anderson a
surgeon on Captain Cook's ship
resolution
although Anderson was in awe most of the
American Christian missionaries who
arrived in Hawaii several decades later
regarded surfing as sinful and they
discouraged it along with other aspects
of native culture the biggest threat to
surfing however was the threat to the
natives themselves by 1890 new illnesses
introduced by Europeans and Americans
had decimated the Hawaiian people
leaving fewer than 40,000 from a
pre-contact population that may have
exceeded 800,000 at the same time for an
influencer group with white settlers
overthrowing the native monarchy in 1893
and the u.s. annexing the islands five
years later the end of Hawaii's
independence coincided with surfing's
native LED revival a revival soon
exploited by the American colonizers but
first some Hawaiians took surfing
overseas in 1907 George Freeth the so
called Hawaiian wonder traveled to the
west coast and gave surfing
demonstrations in Southern California
then in 1914 Olympic swimmer Duke
Kahanamoku made his way to Australia and
New Zealand gliding across the Southern
Pacific waves and attracting rapt
audiences wherever he went
shortly before Freeth went to California
a South Carolinian named Alexander Hume
Ford moved to Hawaii after learning to
surf he became a champion of the pastime
but Ford may have had unsavory reasons
for his enthusiastic efforts to boost
the sport like many settlers he wanted
Hawaii to become a US state but was
worried about its non-white majority of
natives
Asian workers or thus promoted surfing
to attract white Americans to Hawaii
first as tourists then as residents he
was helped by numerous writers and
filmmakers Ford's demographic plan would
fail miserably Hawaii became a state in
1959 and remains the most racially
diverse state in the country but the
promotion of surfing was a far greater
success today surfing is a
multibillion-dollar global industry with
tens of millions of enthusiasts
worldwide and though relatively few of
these surfers are aware of the once
crucial wave chance or board carving
rituals Hawaiians continue to preserve
these traditions nearly washed away by
history's waves if you enjoy ted-ed
lessons please help us make more of them
by supporting our work on patreon.com
slash ted-ed
[Music]